this morning our BBC radio partners
broadcast former President Barack
Obama's first interview since leaving
office he was questioned by Britain's
Prince Harry they sat down in Toronto in
September Barry Petersen is outside the
princes home in London Kensington Palace
with the Royal interview very good
morning the president and the Prince
bonded over the princess charity to help
wounded soldiers in that age-old
journalistic tradition that it's not
what you know but who you know that
counts the former or most eligible
bachelor in the world asked the former
leader of the free world in for a chant
you're going to be faster it was a
mixture of personal life and public
policy there was a reference to social
media something the current tweet loving
president often uses one of the dangers
the Internet is is that people can have
entirely different realities they can be
just cocooned in information that
reinforces their current biases and what
does an ex-president do these days well
for one thing sleeps in the the fact
that I can wake up and if I want to
spend an extra 45 minutes talking to
Michelle mm-hmm and take a long
breakfast mm-hmm I can do it
and what about long-term he's working to
correct climate change something his
successor calls a hoax I can focus over
the next 20 years and making sure that
we don't have more hurricanes and
natural disasters that are accelerated
as a consequence of climate change at
the end
Harry fired off quick questions
including a reference to the TV show
suits that featured his fianceé suits
all The Good Wife suits obviously
great-great-great cigarettes will gum
and gum now baby become White House will
Buckingham Palace White House just
because Buckingham Palace looks like it
would take a really long time to mold in
a separate interview
Harry was asked about Christmas with
Megan Markel joined the royal family and
except for a couple hundred well-wishers
and photographers it sounded
surprisingly normal together we had an
amazing time great fun at staying with
my brother and sister Lauren and they're
running around with her with the kids
and Christmas was Christmas was fat was
fantastic the Wadden couple faced that
age-old nightmare who to invite if they
include the Obamas it might be seen as a
snub to President Trump who's not likely
to make it past the invitation list
first cut
Ladd Barry Petersen in London Barry
thank you very much